[Musique]
nous sommes en voie dans le bretonneux
avec une membre de l'association world
cup event et shuma bougent leur argent
vous allez nous montrer un peu des
exercices d'afro alors d'abord qu'est-ce
que c'est la frau alors enfin il ya la
frau qu'on voit ce sont des réseaux et
puis à la fraude tribal jeudi tribal
convient de différencier les deux du
coup c'est des danses ancestrales qu'on
fait dans différentes pays en afrique
debasement ont la dent ce pieds nus
cette sauce dance pieds nus avec les
tenues traditionnelles et tout ça on va
faire quelques exercices
c'est parti donc on m'a juste levé le
jeu nous voilà maintenant la danseuse
ans a pris comme ça on est toujours plié
les genoux qui échangeraient jeune fille
et le poids du corps au milieu
voilà donc maintenant on va faire 1 2 3
4 et 5 6 7
on va faire le pas ouais donc là c'est
juste le pied en arrière à 2 3 4 et 5
siph c'est suite à des trois caps de
l'autre côté 5 6 7 8 mater policiers de
garder le pied et a toujours ce côté
rebond la voilà ça serait bon là c'est
pour vraiment garder le rythme
[Musique]
c'est un autre exercice que vous pouvez
me montrer ou pas de souci moi je
l'appelle la chaussette la chaussette
on enlève la chaussette voilà comme ça
et on remet va chausser
on ne sait pas toujours mais je vous
refais sa 6 et 5 6 7 8 et 2 3 4 et 5 6 7
8 et 1 2 3 4 et 5 6 7 et en enlève la
chaussette ont remis la chaussette
parler de la chaussette on remet la
chaussée ces conseils cela fait quinze
minutes comment la pratique et l'afro
finalement ce sont des n'est pas assez
simple et accessible à tous des coureurs
en visio sont donnés toutes les semaines
et toutes les informations sont à
retrouver sur leur page facebook et sur
leurs instincts g
ce jour-là un cours de danse freestyle
en visio et donner aux enfants comme aux
adultes le thème carnaval